And so with that context in mind, let's look at how we might approach some shot creation.
So first of all, we want to add a level sequence.
We want to go to the drop down.
We can add level sequence and we can just put that in a new folder here.
So from the main toolbar, we can click that Cinematics button, add level sequence, and
then we can click on the Add Import button, go to the Animation option, find level sequence
as well.
Or you can just right click in the content browser, go to Animation Level Sequence.
So there's two or three different ways you can actually add the level sequence, but essentially
all routes lead to just creating a level sequence within your content browser, which we can
open up.
So once you've got a level sequence, maybe name it master underscore sequence or something
along those lines of the naming convention, and then we're okay to get started.